[Music]
it was just telling you guys I watched
the audio commentary last night it is so
excellent everyone needs to watch it but
right off the bat Kenneth Brandt off
making a little Easter Egg in the movie
that literally is one of those crazy
ideas we had sitting in the Edit room as
two or three weeks before we lacked
picture maybe and we're talking about
you know we needed a great actor to open
the film that had the right gravitas
that make you concern for the Asgardians
why don't we just ask Branagh he's
really greatest actors in the world
luckily he said yes Valkyrie escape
record hopefully off you know ant-man
and the wasp birth there did you guys
have to consciously cut down some of the
characters just get it down to that 23
heroes that small number yeah it's a
tough balance look we we we love the
idea of these movies being a culmination
of everything that's happened in the MCU
so our ambition as storytellers is to
tell the total story and include as many
characters as we can but of course we
want to find the right balance to make
sure that we're not overreaching so to
make sure that like the story that we
are telling with each character is
really compelling and rich so yeah we do
have to find that balance as we step
through the script with yes there were
early drafts in script that were insane
and it probably had 100 speaking parts
different approaches to style in terms
of execution one even had Thanos
narrating most of the movie and
you know so it gave us a lot of
flexibility in terms of how much story
we exam into it but at certain point we
you know get 20 pages and do it was so
dense you're like nobody's gonna be able
to follow this so we just said it's
stripping things out it's it's so
magnificent like it's such a balance if
you will of all the characters but one
of the things you guys mentioned is one
of these insane things was that Captain
America originally didn't show up until
like well into the third act why did you
decide to change that besides you know
the obvious basically because everybody
at Marvel I think other than Joe and I
was mad at us because we're bringing
everybody simply how do we sort of like
we thought it was the right spot to do
it but after a while we kind of gave in
to everybody's like we need more cap he
had Thor's heroic entrance into the
Wakanda battle that was originally
capped and that you know our thinking
was that he was on the run nobody could
find him and so you know we thought that
it would be this really compelling way
to use the character especially because
we're trying to ascend the ranks out so
that we can track everyone and then we
realize we had a really good spot to
bring him in earlier in in Scotland to
save vision and wand and so we started
moving around heroic moments for
characters but that choice about
bringing Captain that was sort of at the
heart of what we the premise of the
movie for us was always that because of
what happened in Captain America Civil
War because captain Tony had the falling
out because the Avengers are divided
this is why they lose to Thanos because
they're not together
they're divided so playing with this
idea of that it's hard for Tony and cap
to get back together on the same team
and have the cap sort of be late to the
party because they they are forced to
live underground and hiding from the
government that was always a basic
premise of the movie for us I did love
that like Tony has all the tech in the
world man just has this like flip burner
phone where is he dad why wouldn't you
were saying if cap gave you a phone you
would carry it around good yes there was
two moments that made me like spit out
my drink watching the commentary and one
being that you guys acknowledge like a
hot daddy Fanus what did you guys make
of all the reactions on the internet to
hot bana I mean listen everybody's got
their their own thing yeah you know he's
a Tony Soprano type you know we're
supportive of whatever your your your
fantasies about tannaz maybe I mean look
again we really wanted to make him a
compelling relatable character and I
think that's just that maybe a dimension
of the fact that he does feel he feel he
feels compelling I think that emotion
can translate or that passion can
translate directly to Josh Brolin
because it really is rolling so and
we're mapping everything that he does so
I think that that's what's unique about
that character is that there really is
the essence of an actor behind him and
that's what people are ascribing to it
the whole third act you know takes place
in Wakanda and you guys were filming in
tandem with Black Panther right that's
right I liked watching some of the high
machine stuff it look like Winston Duke
who plays in Baku kind of gave you guys
some guidance in terms of like the
chants and that kind of stuff like how
much did the kid did the actors lend to
a ton yeah I mean really was like you
know we did a lot of work with Ryan
Coogler prior to shooting and prior to
him shooting once you start shooting and
we're both crazy at that point there's
so much going on that but we you know we
got an incredible amount of information
from him about how he was filling out
Wakanda and the choices that he was
making creatively his team his
production designers cinematographers we
knew a lot about where they're going to
had incredibly detailed maps and the
work that they put in that film was
astounding and so we could glean a lot
of information but obviously things grow
and changes your shooting and we you
know we hadn't connected with each other
for a while
so when the cast showed up they had all
new information for us and we spent a
lot of the morning that we were shooting
that hilltop scene just talking through
you know how things were developing on
the movie and and you know the chance
that we're developing and it's a
Chadwick and deny and Winston were all
integral and and everything that
happened on that hilltop we altered a
lot of our choreography and rewrote it
the morning of based on the ideas that
are bringing having seen black panther
are there certain characters that you're
really hoping to kind of play with a
little more in a vendor's more it's it's
unfortunate because half of them are
gone now but of the ones that are left
yeah than I did I thought amazing work
in the infinite war and I think that
that character is is very powerful and
super compelling and I think there's a
lot of places to go with that character
so her reaction to T'Challa was like
yeah probably the most heart-wrenching
beyond
Iron Man yeah well I say it's her yeah
it's her her goal in life her mission in
life is to protect the king right and
watching him evaporate in front of her
and there's nothing she can do about it
was really taking that that that source
of pride for her and that that duty and
and you know it it challenges her in the
most painful way possible every Marvel
movie has their little Empire Strikes
Back tribute with the loss of the arm
and I really liked the group scene
because it felt so seamless I was
curious what came first the idea that
someone had to lose an arm in the movie
or knowing that group was definitely
going to contribute to Stormbreaker I
was very much about group you know
focusing on
groots growth arc in the film again
going from this moment of being this
very aloof detached teenager who doesn't
really you know can't sort of tie into
to people around him an emotional level
to slowly being drawn into the struggle
that the world is going through in the
film and realizing that at a moment a
very special moment he needs to
contribute today so that's really that's
really what I came from that was such a
cool moment um what do you guys think of
people being so ticked off at star-lord
yeah I mean I look he you know he's a
character who's gone through a lot of
pain and he's lost a lot of people in
his life he was kidnapped by pirates
when he was 10 years old
raised by pirates lost his mother had to
kill his father
and in the movie you know his the love
of his life is taken from him so I don't
know if you can't understand someone
making a human choice like that mm-hmm
then I don't know if you understand
humanity very well but he is a he's just
a you know he's a flawed character and
that's what's so compelling about him in
that moment that that moment is very
emotionally truthful you know and I
think that's that's why we bought it in
the moment that's and that's why we
loved it as a storytelling point because
it made it so well vulnerable but you
know there's lots of choices they have
characters have made throughout the
movie that sort of led them to lose it
wasn't simply that moment you know the
if you again if you go back to the end
of the Civil War the entire the entire
riff between cap and Tony is sort of a
basis for why they lose in this film you
know Thor Thor gets the drunk jump on
panels at the end of the film but
instead of sort of killing him quickly
he sort of does it in a way where he can
draw out his revenge
sure and engage with with Thanos in a
way that God really gives them away
now get away so there there there you
know these that's what we love about
these characters you know they're
superheroes they have amazing powers but
makes it what makes them vulnerable is
their emotional life and their and their
and their emotional needs and that's
where things get complicated and that's
where the story's really and I think
it's important I have empathy in life is
it's to have empathy for these
characters so if anything for us making
challenging choices and flawed choices
with the characters is a way for us to
convey the notion that you know empathy
is is it's critical to to living life
properly yeah somebody said in the
commentaries like that's what a human
would do and that that like has been
sticking with me all day and well yeah
absolutely one of the most memed moments
is also the most heart-wrenching the
moment with Peter Parker
since you guys introduced Peter Parker
and then taketh away
did you feel that sort of paternal thing
over that character as well like how
heart-wrenching was that for you guys
yeah but we have a really close
relationship with Tom Hall and we loved
him you know we fought for him and
casting and you know it was a very
specific interpretation of that
character because spider-man was my
favorite character growing up and I
think over the years he had been a you
know he'd been played by actors who were
in their twenties rather than an actor
was a teenager and I thought that that
was an integral part to translating
Peter Parker the screen was this sort of
in this you know youthful buoyancy and
this it's kids struggling with pimples
while I was you know struggling with
superpowers so to take him on that
journey we knew it was gonna be
heartbreaking cuz a heartbreaking for us
and you know on set watching and I was
tearing up because you know again that's
my favorite character and I had a
feeling that would translate in a way
that would be very painful everyone else
I thought well if this is and this is
hurting us watching it then we're going
in the right direction because this is
the point of the film is that you know
sometimes villains win and and not
everybody makes it out alive so to take
him on that journey was very special
again cuz he was such a favorite
character but happy
credit to Robert Downey 2 for drawing
that out of Wow yeah you know that you
know he's an amazing performer Robert we
all know but like you know one of the
one of those three gifts is his ability
to engage other actors around them and
sort of pull their best work out of them
and I think you can see the relationship
between Robert and Tom the entire way
through right here they've had that kind
of dynamic in London but how do you feel
that Tom Holland spent the entire press
tour spoiling aspects of the movie over
and over what are you gonna do they
start of he's the nicest guy in the
world so you know never be punitive
towards a judge Tom Holland people made
like super cuts of it was my favorite
thing of everything he spoiled yeah like
15 minutes salmon Benedict Cumberbatch
and Benedict cover that's just being
like Benedict is a great partner for him
on the press tour because Benedict is
actually very good at dancing around
spoilers and monitoring tomahawk
[Music]